I'm here with three other gamers to put
a VIP anthem demo I've never met that
before but we have to play together as a
team whether we like it or not the game
is going to force us to play together
it's gonna be fun I am very excited to
see how this turns out
just something interesting I want to
jump into the game
alright boys we have silenced the two
relics and now it is our objective to
find a way underground through this
disgusting bug tunnel yep and locate the
egg source dxis
a source of the omelette scramble egg
source you guys we don't know but that's
actually a very popular British
condiment here so I won't have you
mocking my heritage I think that's the
last of the bugs we probably did
everything we needed to do and
everything will be fine man yeah
definitely
I was we're not gonna have any issues
with any eggs any born no I won't need X
anymore in my life you ruin my breakfast
forever it's gonna be a while before I
have an omelet I think I think I'm gonna
take it like a grim satisfaction in my
next omelet oh look at this huge there's
a huge one Oh fight of the shield okay
so explore the tunnels I think we need
to go this way until I reach a dead end
yeah I tried that once with you guys
maybe this yeah this way yeah sounds
like oh boy this is like water something
there's a lot of tunnel sir
oh no bugs oh let me catch up yeah Oh
exploding spiders oh yes there they are
my nightmare okay all right good what
did he sort of like pagoda statues and
our compass think that's probably where
we want to go all right yes sounds like
a waterfall or something you're just
getting loud oh it gets it is getting
louder yes good point
the egg waterfall there's a lot of eggs
there ooh
there's even eggs on the wall on ceiling
oh I don't like them going in the
ceiling at all yeah crawling hey guy
very efficient there is a lot of acid
from those boys out of ammo I said I
don't know if you can see it there's
some ammo on the ground right in the
middle there where straight ahead in the
middle oh yeah that another big hole the
ground we encourage to flare I'm
supposed to use players who's jumping
for water yeah yeah you smile uh it is
very dark down area was it is very dark
uh okay maybe this way which ways up
probably this way I think you guys have
found the way out already
yeah okay oh there is a very big dead
spider here but it's dead
is it dead I hope I'm not sure oh-ho oh
oh it's only a scorpion
car that's to think of what Oh God ah
yeah okay
no we got to the area I guess this is
Nick source what are we going to fight
in this row look up I think it might be
this guy oh oh I do not like him oh
that's a that's a very eggy
Saeki okay thing that is definitely a
Saeki eggy bug I'm gonna snipe him off
the swarm tyrants all right tyrants ah
I'm whipped up and I'm really gross down
with my nickname it's cool oh my god oh
this is super gross
I have no I'm okay so go go Matt look is
everybody good oh yes so basically if
you target the this the fleshy bits you
get so if you can get to get a shot in
their fleshy parts oh yeah definitely
some crit damage to get well
I'm going close-combat guys do it oh it
jumped at me sorry I'm very rocky phobic
I thought you liked spiders I'm going
alright wear it I've lost it where is it
yeah it's on the ceiling above yet it's
right o mo yeah kill the babies there
arrabal I'll feed some of these guys up
again okay where's the swarm Tyrone oh
there's a lot of people alright so big
bugs I didn't really see that comment
but I should have got it I can feel it
in my neck
yeah hey
Oh valves shipping back I see the swamp
tyrant has very hurt health bars
reappeared which makes me think he's
gonna be enough oh god run okay wait sit
yes he was just there oh there he is
yeah yeah nice all right okay Oh same ol
time all right that's one - okay he's
runnin lipo sniper for me sniper oh oh
he's getting back on the ceiling no
first night book oh I know my evo yes
some really good crit damage there just
was he was climbing up I think he's
quite vulnerable when he's planning
oh we got some I got a lot of guys
coming in here yet bro holding
Arriva this is super gross there's a
bunch of them coming out of the wall
yeah hey I gotta go he's back he's back
from the dead yeah Oh
ah webbed
ah one more come to
someone's dead what frogs nope she says
he's about stuck climbing they yeah my
alters ready and I'm looking for him
he's about to disappear I wouldn't use
it now oh yeah well I got a chunk there
watch out with Jeff max well okay so
let's kill some more bugs well waste
farther it's by the time
this is immensely satisfying just mowing
down a bunch of disgusting pugs when
you're all in one place
feels like in my basement
Oh Derek well there he is yeah
oh he's so he's kind of small
Oh Oh guys please we're so close
oh please so close I'm right here heaven
help me
hello do you have him next I'm right
right there with you I'll save you many
times you gonna leave me like that okay
oh thank you coming in Thank You Mac
come on repair it repair repair please
Mac I got you
thank you Oh getting the hell out of
there oh he is down oh okay
thank you thanks nice Wow
the trophy get the body back completes
nicely done everyone that's what made
the eggs
yeah well ception a whack that is a
strong hold and we did it we killed the
giant thing that made the eggs and it
genuinely scared me I don't know what I
was expecting I was thinking something
more reptilian but I'm so naive those
were some some real good squeals a lot
of critters a lot of slime squeal the
right word I don't know it's like when
you're cooking a lobster and it's just a
baby I wish I didn't die
despite from the day the spider from the
death ah in spider
I mean I'll admit I'm Ted I'm terrible
at this but I I'm enjoying the process
of playing it and I really want to see
what it's like when you get a full squad
of people who know what they're doing
the gear that's their favorite yeah I
all know how to use those combos
successfully because we pull one of
those off but you know what I'm also
thinking as well is that especially when
it starts getting harder and harder and
we're getting into those really
difficult fights that you know even if
we all get completely annihilated that
we can come back change up our gear for
what we know is gonna work yeah like
yeah you know when you can freeze the
turrets and stop them shooting at you
yes that works so well to stay
Princetonian bigger 100% just look at
all the stuff we got out of that yeah oh
and I love how the classes play all day
oh yes so the Interceptor
does the smiley stuff without any
cooldown and just just the interceptors
it's just a huge difference to the
Ranger especially with this media
attacks so yeah I'm looking forward for
the new loot because oh yeah we need to
we need to gear up on you guys yeah yeah
I really want to try playing because the
the storm was super agile especially in
the air you know I can just hang in the
air above the battlefield for ages and
see see you guys like scuttling around
taking everyone out and I can just like
puppet master it from up top but now I
really want to try like the Colossus I
bet it's gonna feel completely different
it's like a kind of a different game
yeah I mean I you know did the Ranger in
the Colossus and it's just Ranger yeah
my cake well I must say guys was another
yeah yeah mate and I'm duty get me I
gotta say like told you I never played
the game before and the game it took me
like two minutes to get the game in my
hands yeah the game place so crazy and
the possibilities like the combos once
you master it you know the the salt and
and and and the boost and the grenades
and the snipe and it's it's really
really amazing when it all starts to
come together I just feel like a silky
smooth it's incredible anything can do
and solo and like you say max and the
team with all the capacities and the and
and the Granger cause it's it's really
crazy this is the demo will stay on
track and not run around and explore
yeah or pay too much attention to the
story so yeah no I can't I can't wait to
play it yeah I'm sorry I'm really glad
that I got to play with you guys as well
because it was great yeah you made me
look real good and I'm already dreading
reading the comments that's just I do
it's not holding my own there I'm gonna
yeah I'll get my Ranger I'm gonna
customize it even crazier yeah I'm gonna
be the number one
well number two up to you I can't wait
to spend just like a solid three hours
in the in the customization yes I'm just
just the paint yes yeah and then you can
save all of your presets as well so you
can just jump in with each
one of your right I'm going full shiny
on my next one mm-hmm
solid gold anyway that was it thank you
again guys yeah thank you everyone a
pleasure and that was the anthem VIP
demo we did it we brought the team
together all of us are experts with our
javelins don't forget there's going to
be a live stream of anthem over on
GameSpot on launch day which is February
22nd I'll see you there